على صعيد اخر يبدا رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الاسبق وزعيم وحزب الليكودي
بنيامين لجنياهو اليوم الاحد يبدا مشاورات
اوليه ولقاءات مع رؤساء الاحزاب المرشحه
للمشاركه في ائتلافه الحكوميه ويلتقين
اسرائيل ورئيس حزب ضيق الهجرات ورئيس حزب
الصهيونيه دينيه
مسبقا انه سيطلب سيطلب لحزبه حقيبه الامن
الداخلي مع توسيع الصلاحيات المخوله
الوزير شعره لان لاذاعه العبريه نقلت عن
مصادر نتنياهو
مقربه بانه سيسرع من جهوده وتشكيل حكومته
لتقديمها في اول جلسه للكنيسه الجديده في
الخامس عشر من الشهر الجاي
يا ماما ولينا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري مرحبا بك معنا وليد
اذا لنجم الساعات الماضيه هذه الحاله من
التوتر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وكيف انعكست
ايضا في اتصال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي مع
الرئيس الفلسطيني
مصعب مثل الليله الماضيه واصابه زميلا له
في منطقه تعرب في وادي الحراميه قريبه من
قريه السنجل وهي شمالي مدينه رام الله
الذريعه التي استخدمها الاحتلال انهما كان
يرسقان السيارات المستوطنين بالحجاره لكن
هذه الذريعه مشكوك في ضيقتها وصحتها لان
الساعات كانت ساعات ليل وهذا الشارع تسلكه
السيارات الفلسطينيه وسيارات المستوطنين
ومن الصعب تمييز سيارات المستوطنين عن
سيارات الفلسطينيين بالليل وواضح من طريقه
قتل بان الرصاصه اصابته في القلب بانه كان
مستهدفا بمعنى انه كانت هناك عمليه قنص
مباشر له وبذلك يصعب يصعب الشهيد مصعب نفل
الشهيد او 95
الذي تقتله قوات الاحتلال في منذ بدايه
العام الحالي في عهد هذه الحكومه المنصرفه
الوضع اراضي الفلسطينيه كان محور الاتصال
الذي اجراه بلانكن مع الرئيس الفلسطيني
هذا الاتصال عكس قلقا امريكيا وان كان من
وجهه نظر بعد الفلسطينيين ليس اكثر من
ضريبه كلاميه هدفها وحاول اطمئنه
الفلسطينيين بان الولايات المتحده باقي
على موقفها بخصوص حل الدولتين بان هناك
خشيه واضحه سواء لدى الاداره الامريكيه او
لدى القياده الفلسطينيه والدها اوساط في
حلبه السياسيه الاسرائيليه خاصه الحكومه
المنصرفه من ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المقبله التي ستكون برئاسه بنيامين
نتنياهو وستكون هي حكومته السادسه منذ ان
اعتل سجده الحكم في الصعيد عام 69 حتى
يومنا هذا وتضم همم تيارات واحزاب فاشيه
عنصريه تجاهر وتعلن بانها تريد ان تضم
الضفه الغربيه ولا تعترف بحل الدولتين هذا
الاتصال من جانب كان جاء في محاوله
للتاكيد بان الولايات المتحده ستبقى على
هذا الموقف لكن يرى الفلسطينيون ووفقا ما
جاء في بيان الخارجيه الفلسطينيه قبل قليل
بان المجتمع الدولي وتحديدا الولايات
المتحده تتحمل المسؤوليه عن صمطها على
جرائم الاسرائيليه التي اذا تواصلت كما
قالت فانها ستقضي على ما تبقى من بصيص امل
حول احتمال الوصول الى مثل هذا الحل هذه
الحكومه المقبله في اسرائيل شرعا نتنياهو
منذ اللحظه الاولى الحقيقه ويبدو انه كان
قد رتب اوراقه حتى قبل الانتخابات شرع
بتوزيعه حقائبها على حلفائه الثلاث وهم
الصهيونيه الدينيه وهذا حزب فاشي واضح
وحزب شاص لليهود الشرقيه وحزب حدودها
تراها الذي همم وهو لليهود الغربيين فلا
يبدو انه سيواجه مشاكل كبيره مع هذه
الاحزاب ربما يواجه بعض التحدي في توزيع
طيب داخل همم حزبه لانه هناك لدى قائد بعض
قاده حزب اطمعا بان يحصلوا على حقائب
سياديه كبيره ولا يبدو ان نتنياهو سيكون
قادر على توزيعها او يرغب في ذلك لان
حلفائه من اليمين الفاشل تحديدا قد حددوا
مطالبهم مطالبهم بشكل واضح وجلي شكرا
جزيلا لك وليد انا عمري مدير مكتب الجزيره
من رام الله